we'll have plenty of gold in the sky
today guys don't worry about that
we got our own gold and it's going to be
hot gold we've got
heat warning still in effect happy
thursday everybody
and good morning this is the time of day
to get out enjoy whatever you want to do
outdoors take that walk that jog that
bike ride
walk the dog because we're going to heat
up pretty quickly again through the
morning some neighborhoods have not even
dropped below 90 degrees
like green valley right there on the
strip even summerlin and we've got
breezes
west summerlin has been getting a little
bit of that southwest breeze that red
rock has had
early this morning we've had wind gusts
out there already to 25 miles an hour
that's the first taste
of those southwest breezes that we're
going to get through the day and
especially this afternoon into tonight
and again on friday
82 in boulder city 81 in mesquite upper
70's for indian springs still around the
century mark for death valley
123 degrees there yesterday 61 up the
road in cedar city
and mid 60's for cali any this morning
we're going to sizzle again this
afternoon
up near record highs in the 1 teens with
that heat warning in effect until 8
o'clock tonight
those are all areas below 4 000 feet so
the mountains are
not included in that breezy southwest
winds will start gaining some strength
today
and then they will keep going tonight
and
probably still pretty bumpy for friday
as well those excessive heat warnings
all these areas you see of deep pink
those will stay in effect until eight
o'clock tonight so
clark county southern nye county mohave
county arizona and over into southeast
california
the reason for the wind there's a system
moving into northern california
up into northern nevada it's brought a
few little isolated
showers boy all those wildfires in
oregon and california
they sure could have used a lot more
rain but it'll work against our high
pressure to crank those winds
to about 25 maybe 30 miles an hour 112
today
close to that record of 113 we might
even make it to 113
breezy tomorrow but temperatures back
off about 5 degrees
our normal high goes down to 103 for
friday and you can see we'll stay above
that our back to school
forecast staying hot and sunny next week
105
even inching up to 106 or seven and no
monsoon
thunderstorms in the forecast we're
staying hot and dry